Now, I think this is a really difficult concept, so fair warning, this might be
confusing. If you're totally good on this, awesome, move forward. If not, you
might want to spend a little bit of extra time trying to understand this
concept. Since we said that we can substitute really whatever we want in the
place of x, I can actually substitute in a different expression that involves an
x. So here we have a function defined with x as the independent variable. And in
the place of a independent variable I can plug in x squared for example.
Remember that these variables are really just place holders for us to plug in,
other numbers that we know that they can equal. And if we decide that we want to
plug in x squared, we are totally entitled to do that. So, how would you write
out, in simplest terms, what f of x squared is? And yes, please remember to
simplify as much as you can.